anyone who has a diabolical mind would
do diabolical things to just treat
people in an in inhumane way as you guys
know it is one of the few jobs of the
president of the United States to defend
the Border that's part of what the
federal government is supposed to do the
Democrats are not doing that it's
intentional I have no doubt that it is
intentional uh and then places like New
York which have become Sanctuary cities
start getting pissed because uh other
places that don't want all these
illegals like Texas which of course is a
border state with mexic
uh Governor Abbott up in over down in
Texas he has been sending people via bus
to New York City and Eric Adams is not
happy about it as we show you this video
of Eric Adams I just I have this feeling
that he's actually a robot from here
down that it's a robotic body and
they've just put a head on him that's a
sidebar to all this but it's worth
noting have you been outsmarted by the
Texas governor Greg Abbott uh no anyone
who has a diabolical mind would do
diabolical things to just just treat
people in an in inhumane way we handled
over 164,000 migrants and Asylum Seekers
and we're doing it in a humane way we're
very clear that we're going to continue
to adjust as the governor of Texas carry
out these actions to make sure that we
send a very clear and Loud message no
bus company should be participating in
this action and we're going to
communicate with our partners in this
region and make sure that we tell them
they should file the same level of
executive order to stop this from taking
place okay this is rather extraordinary
and this is what they do with everything
so again it's his party it's the
Democrats that are allowing everybody in
Greg Abbott is a republican he's saying
hey we don't want these people in Texas
you Eric Adams you're a sanctuary city
mayor you've got all these resources
apparently and you're not diabolical I'm
Greg Abbot I'm diabolical I'm a
republican I'm racist duh I'm white take
them why don't you want them anymore and
by the way it is not Humane to take
these people and then give them these
crumbs that you give them because it's
not Humane to the good taxpaying people
who live in New York City if there's any
decent people in New York City left my
mother-in-law lives there for some God
godforsaken reason I'm trying to get her
down here to Florida but you are not
being Humane to the people who are
actually the functioning people in the
system